why was that so hard oh god okay
this isn't so bad
what's up guys i'm q and i'm elise and
today we're going to be doing a us army
fitness test with zero practice
none
so the test consists of three exercises
the first one is going to be push-ups
we'll have two minutes to do as many as
we can
and there's going to be no breaks
sit-ups same thing
as many reps as possible in two minutes
the final one is going to be a two
minute mile mile
the third and final exercise is a two
mile run so we need a score of 50 per
exercise to pass and if by some chance
we get a 90 per exercise we'll get a
army
fitness badge and that's pretty badass
if you ask me we're gonna go for that
50.
let's get it yeah okay ready and you're
going for 68 if you want that 90th
percentile
okay ready set go
look at that form
don't hit me left right has ten
20 that was 16 i counted 16.
well come on keep going
one more one more oh my god that shake
you've got 10 seconds do five more
[Music]
you don't even know how hard that was
five
four three two one
go
oh that doesn't count
[Music]
oh god
[Music]
oh i gotta get back up
five four three
two one oh my god
oh my god why was that so hard
how many there's a couple questionable
ones in there oh god all right that's
the push-ups down
now it's time for sit-ups
[Music]
come on keep going what the hell
i think did i get that right
my body the sun there's so much going on
five four three two
one
[Music]
how much time that was it oh good job
all right guys so that was the push
system sit-ups we both passed now it's
time for the two-mile run
i'm not looking forward to this i don't
feel good about it but
hey let's go my plan is to pace myself
10 minutes a mile that's what i'm going
for
okay i'm ready all right one two
three go
[Music]
i was actually feeling all right and i'm
like hey
this isn't so bad and then i looked at
the time
thinking i was like halfway that's been
five minutes
[Music]
elise is running kind of fast right now
like her pace is her pace is really good
[Music]
oh my gosh she's running the mark
you got it you got it
glad i went first and got that over with
that was no joke
yeah um are you ready to go um
yeah i'm ready five four
three two and go
i've never ran a mile before my life
now that i run too
[Music]
come on spread spread
20 44 i'm so tired
what's the time did i miss it
let's go army here i come
all right guys i'm officially done with
the us army fitness test i passed
i passed the push-ups past the sit-ups
and a two-mile run
and i missed it by seven seconds on the
two-mile run um so yeah good luck here
[Music]
you